hey guys I'm Ryan right hey there I'm
Veronica I'm Jelena so we have Veronica
muzic and blogger Selena color my energy
which is very artistic poems and song
sort can i it's an amazing experience
festival we come and express yourself
our whole mission statement is to
inspire others to find their passion
some people don't know what their
passion is and it's important and we are
all artists some of us just haven't
unleashed our art Veronica explain your
channel to Mike um look I'm a musician I
write songs I'm a singer and I play the
guitar I do mostly covers I haven't
posted much originals yet but there will
be originals what I really like to do on
the channel is document my adventures
and most of them involve Ryan right
because he's my babe and I does
everything with me so yeah we we have
fun so check that out okay our
relationship is more personal I know I
just got out of third wheel oh yeah I
brought them here because they clearly
are not involved in the gaming life I've
seen a lot of these trailers a Mortal
Kombat X you know you kind of become
immune to them and after a while you
can't really review them so this is just
gonna be a genuine reaction because
these two are some of the most honest
most expressive people in life I've ever
met oh so here we go I have no four
I now have a quarrel
much
Oh
bedtime wins well that's my brother's
birthday happy brother sorry I decided I
like the only game that I could actually
play because I would push the buttons
and whatever they yeah yeah right you
just press like whatever I pressed I
went bad you know threw out a punch or
kick can be able to not just defend
myself so that I liked that game yeah
and then if you would happen to Mortal
Kombat I have no [ __ ] idea easy he got
better hmm
he got better Wow that's what happened
baby I like this kind of stuff I think
about this kind of stuff all the time
it usually involves like different
ethnicities is it for like PlayStation
we were having a very nice conversation
that are late into the video and here
she is wanting to ask questions about
the game I don't know I think it comes
out like PlayStation 4
do you ever think about doing that to
your boyfriend like just really crushing
it guys none at all
yeah I do like how they just come back
to life though quite a bit are you
saying you want to crush my head but
it's okay because you'll come back maybe
feel better do it it's kind of
comforting knowing that the character
still exists you know it just can pop
back to life ya know in the last one he
was he was gone the last kill when the
acid was melt in his face and then he
crushed his skull he was dead at that
point did that guy just throw up acid
but like yeah he's a reptile spits acid
at you yeah it wins do reptiles this
[ __ ] in the Mortal Kombat 90's movie
he's [ __ ] scary anyway guys thanks for
tuning in if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out Veronica's channel you
can check out Selena's Channel and [ __ ]
it we're gonna do one shoutout
Filipe Batista what a painful no
Philippe it's very big I believe out of
the two of us I speak Spanish the best
Felipe number two l Taco Bell oh what a
Brian you gotta say I enjoy your channel
and all your guests too especially the
ladies okay
Oh home boom boom boom come now come
here baby
it was subtly on me oh yeah I'm totally
fine just being awkward with a corner
it's okay I'm okay I'm comfortable with
myself she's she's here just for you I
love my Velma but that's that's besides
the point
I would love a shout-out and like your
American sniper review I agree with you
100% god bless and much love this is a
very sincere message what a great guy
indeed Batista you dude make this
[ __ ] man oh yeah man's
[ __ ] wanna cry real awesome
Felipe
that's his crying face he's doing is
he's doing his crying face guys I put
you Felipe for you I cry for you Felipe
your shoutout but like it really good
shot